this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
am i expecting it to change my life
better
this is the melon immersion literally
why is it so expensive again there's
like protections for the farmers
[Music]
wow
bundles of juice just
exploding in my mouth
good girl
these are 50 strawberries from japan i
decided to get them and compare them to
regular strawberries just to see if it's
worth the hefty price
[Music]
chocolate covered strawberries
chocolate in your mouth
strawberry oh my god magic chocolate
strawberry
the strawberries aren't very juicy
fancy strawberry
[Music]
oh my god
i'm literally tearing up i'm losing
heaven and it doesn't even taste like a
strawberry let's just start there this
is like a pinch like a nectarine or like
a really nice grape you can see why this
is 50
what i grew up knowing to be what a pear
was the pair that i that my mom would
raise prepare for me
what should i say
i think that wasn't right because i was
way tankier than expected who's good
rain beard
[Music]
the korean pear is just so much juicier
crunchier it's like you're biting into
an apple it's almost sweet like a peach
oh wow it's like really crispy it's
almost like watermelon
this
it's like a caramel in your mouth
cotton candy breaks for comparison i did
get regular green grapes i don't look
too fancy right but um
like you can take
it's so juicy
as great as a grape guess
it literally tastes like cotton candy
last night i decided to freeze some hot
candy ribs
little sorbets frozen grapes already
fantastic treat but frozen cotton candy
grapes
next level pink pineapple definitely way
more expensive than your average
pineapple
shirt
whoa i didn't cut it the same because i
don't know how to
and as for taste
that's a pineapple an aesthetic
pineapple i'll give it this
it's a bit more dense than a regular
pineapple the way a regular pineapple
peels and kind of a little flakier you
know what this pineapple is
way less tangy
after a while when you eat the yellow
pineapple makes your mouth hurt like i
could eat way more of these than the
yellow ones
you